6 24 on your wednesday morning so the
deadline is next week if you want to
chime in on that nevada department of
transportation improvement project for
red rock canyon as well as for blue
diamond and prompt
we look forward to developing
recommendations for how to continue to
operate these roadways safely and
efficiently as the region continues to
grow that's the director of the nevada
department of transportation christina
swallow talking about what's called the
state route 160 and state route 159
corridor study as our valley grows
traffic continues to increase on state
route 160 primarily due to ongoing
growth and development along the
corridor and just to make sure you know
state route 160 that's the main road
between las vegas and prom and state
route 159 that's charleston heading west
of town to red rock canyon then around
the spring mountain ranch state park and
the town of blue diamond recreational
activities along state route 159 are
also increasing which means that we need
to look at how we move everyone
people in cars people on bikes and
people walking
so if any of that describes you and or
your family maybe you should check out
ndot's website there's a lot of stuff
there including the opportunity to tell
them what you think before the end of
the day next wednesday the 27th so we
got that link at 8newsnow.com when you
click traffic then what's driving you
crazy buckle up drive carefully please
put down the phone something driving you
crazy the email address traffic 8 news
now dot com